je vais vous installer par par petits
groupes vous prenez dans les boîtes à
outils des sécateurs un sécateur et une
bonne paire de gants voilà la brigade de
bénévoles équipés pour mener à bien la
mission taillée des essences végétales
locales qui deviendront des aides donc
la réduction du système racinaire
et puis donc on réduit dans la partie
aérienne pour garder ici on a trois
étages de bourgeons ça va permettre à
ramifications de leur bus dès le
démarrage
j'ai bien écouté les consignes je pense
avoir tout compris oui là je veux que à
la sainte catherine tout bois prend
racine comme on dit pour que l'adage se
vérifie il faut mettre ces milliers de
plants en terre entre les mains des
planteurs plusieurs d'espèces sur au
charme épines noires place des pousses
darde ses espèces différentes
là on a fait des trous tout à l'heure
sur la bâche et là on en compte les
pauses et c'est bien parce que plus il y
en à différents plus ça va attirer des
animaux différents
on essaye de faire en sorte à un niveau
local sur la commune de vernou sur
brenne et de noizay avec l'aide du
conseil départemental d'indre et loire
et de la fédération de chasse d'essayer
de recréer un système plus accueillant
pour la faune sauvage non seulement les
espèces de gibier celle qu'on peut
chasser mais aussi tous les passereaux
tous les insectes un milieu qui
fonctionne bien d'un point de vue
écologique
cette plantation de haies s'inscrit dans
ce que l'on appelle l'agroforesterie
une pratique qui existe depuis des
siècles pendant plus de 70 ans les et
champêtre ont été arrachés pour agrandir
les exploitations et faire de
l'agriculture intensive n'ont arraché v
et on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que on en a
probablement un peu trop harrach est
clair que là elle elle a une fonction
mécanique de ralentir la progression
l'eau de pluie est là elle a un rôle
aussi de chimique de filtrer de filtrer
l'eau est de permettre à l'eau aussi de
descendre dans les nappes plutôt que de
ruisseler en surface de partir dans des
fossés de partir à la mer cette parcelle
cultivée depuis des années va revenir à
l'état de prairies pour accueillir des
animaux quand c'est et or ont pris un
peu de hauteur d'ici environ cinq ans